okay hello
my name is guillaume cedric marty i'm
french but i'm living in the uk so
hopefully my
bad accent won't cause you any headaches
so today i'm going to
speak about uh fast retro gaming and
video game emulation on mobile so
just a quick poll how many of you were
born in the 90s
okay in the 80s
okay and the 70s okay good
so for most of these guys uh probably
get some
get some uh bring back some uh good
memories for
from your childhood okay so let's start
um so if you this is actually
the intro from a mega man
game on on net so i just it would be a
nice introduction to my talk so
um there you go
so the title of a talk is 60
fps retro gaming on mobile so
as you know the current state of
javascript
at the moment javascript is fast enough
for
doing emulation
uh and it's also good because it's
cross-platform so you don't have to
uh to build different binaries depending
on the platform you want
to to ship your emulator and also
it's the only way to have video game
emulation
on uh web-based os's think of
firefox os for example and also it's the
only legal way to get emulation on
on ios unless of course you you have
your jailbreak your your iphone
so um today on this talk i'm going to go
through different techniques for uh
emulation so the first one is the it's
called
interpreter and the second one is called
recompiler
and are going to explain you the
techniques used and
uh which one to go especially
uh if you want to build fast emulation
on
mobile okay so
um the first thing you have to do when
you want to do emulation is to
get a rom file a wrong image file so
basically
uh emulation uses
so a rom file is actually a binary file
representing a cartridge of
a video game so it's a binary file so
it's just
a certain amount of of
data so have a look at this so this is a
kind of javascript representation of a
rom file so
this is the beginning of the game gear
version of the game gear version of a
japanese version of columns
so what's on the screen is actually a
copyrighted material but i
believe it's legal for me to show you
because i own the original video game
so um so what this is what we get
if we when we want to to do emulation we
just get
a large binary file so what we have to
do
is to place this big binary file into a
javascript buffer and then we
we feed this buffer into a data view and
we place this dataview into a variable
called rom so that will be
that will allows us to um
to require to get some data actually
from
from this rom file um
so the first thing we need is a variable
that we most of the time
it's called pc that stands for for
program counter so basically this
variable uh
is a a pointer to the current extraction
being uh executed in a in the in a
in a rom file so in this example i'm
going to take
so this v as an example i'm going to use
uh the explain the emulation on master
system and game gear
both of these consoles they're very
similar hardware so
emulation is very it's very
it's kind of the same we can emulate
both system very easily
so on this system the entry point in the
rom file
is uh the data located at index
zero so at the beginning of a program
we define a pc variable to zero
then we read what we call knob code
which i believe stand for operation
operation code i i don't know i don't
yeah okay
by the way if you're familiar with very
low level
i mean cpu level
programming and assembler this is going
to be very
very easy for you to get it so
let's get back to to this so the upcode
is basically
the unsigned 8-bit integ integer
located at the position of pc so what we
do is we
using the dataview
get uint 8
so passing the position of pc as an
argument
we place this value into the upcode
and if you remember from the previous
slide when i show you the
beginning of a binary file the first
value was
c3 so when we do emulation it's very
common to use
hexadecimal notation so
because i don't really know why but
because it's
it's makes it's easier so the first
value is
uh hexadecimal value c3 so this exit
decimal value c3
gives us the
gives us uh actually tells us what
should what should the cpu do
so in this case uh the instruction for
this particular cpu
is gp gp stands for uh
jump so when you do a jump we basically
uh transfer the execution of a program
to somewhere else in the rom file
so to decode the opcode
we just place it into a big switch and
for so our first case is c3
and as i told you a jump transfer the
execution of a program to somewhere else
in the room so what we need to do
is actually update the value of pc
and to know what we call a gem target to
know what will be the new value of pc
we just have to read the unsigned intege
uh unsigned 16 bits integer
at the current position of pc so if you
notice on the
second line i've incremented the
position of pc
so so
now if you rewind and go back at the
first slide
you'll see that the second and third
value
is 007e exactly small value 07e
so we update the value of pc so now pc
is 007e and what we do from now
is we uh we start
again so we put everything in a in a
loop
and then so on the second time on the
uh we will read the uh value for the up
code at 007e
and then we'll have to implement the
matching instruction
in the switch so that's it we just
interpreted the rom
congratulations so this approach
is actually the most
basic way to implement an emulator in
javascript or in any other language
so it's very easy well i mean of course
in this case it's just a very
simple i remove a lot of details but
it's relatively easy to to develop an
interpreter
however it's it's a bit slow especially
on mobile so it can be okay on
on desktop on mobile is definitely too
slow so
we need to find another approach so the
id
of this of our approach is so let's say
we have
a particular rom a rom file so we know
the idea would be to compile this from
file into a javascript into pure
javascript function
so if we taking this example we would
have an object called instruction with
several properties the first one would
be
0 0 and we know whenever the pc
is as value 0 0 we know that what we
want to do is update its value to 007e
okay and then uh the
property 07e um when invest in
so in this case we need to implement the
behavior to um
to mimic the um uh
the instruction that we want to do so
then what we need to do is just to wrap
everything in a while loop
and then there we go so
this is whoops this is what we call
uh recompilation so
most of the time so there are many
different way to
uh to build the recompiler but on the
one i'm going to uh
to talk about there are uh four main
main components so the first one is a
parser
then there is an analyzer an optimizer
and at the end a generator
okay so let's go through all of these
components
so the first parser as you seen at the
beginning of a talk
what we get is it's just a huge binary
file where everything is mixed
together so we can't really just by
looking at the file we can't really tell
the instruction apart from the
appearance
from the the data used for the
the sprites or the background and all
the
behavior used for the uh
the bosses ia for example
so that's why we need the parser to to
try to
make it clear what's what is instruction
and
what is uh all the other type of data
okay
so then what we get from this
parser is sent to the analyzer so
this part is actually fundamental in an
emulation
because what it does it kind of
recreates
a natural javascript or unnatural
look code from a binary file so
it must recreate the control flow using
a javascript instruction like if if
for while etc
and and and and that's it
so then we have the optimizer so the
optimizer is as the name
implies make sure the code runs as fast
as possible
and then uh yes however this step is
purely optional and we can just
remove it and the compiler is going to
run
normally i'd say and then of course at
the end
what we need is is a javascript code and
this is the role of a generator okay
so now i'm going to show you the flow of
data because at the beginning
what we start with is uh binary data
taken directly from the rom file so this
is the
input that is sent to the parser
then the parser output an area of byte
code so a byte code is just
a structured structured
structured element that tells for that
that show for each um each instruction
which what is the up code what is the
operand etc but we can't do
much with just bytes codes so then
we have the analyzer so the
the byte code go through the analyzer
and then
we get as an output an is an ast
so in this particular exam example
i'm using an ist so
that's what we called an ir which sent
for
intermediate representation and i've
decided to use
a javascript ast how however
it's it's it's a simplified ist
with um um
not with because what we need to do is
apply
many um
many we need to process that this this
information in in many different ways so
if the easier ast we get the
easier it is to to do all this
processing
uh however
it has um if i had to
rewrite it now i would probably wouldn't
go for an ist because it's very
complicated
my idea was i was maybe a bit naive but
i was thinking okay if i
if i have a javascript ast then i
probably going to be able to reuse
uh optimization passes um uh
developed for of a project i'm thinking
in particular to
uh what's it called is it uh
es mangle which is a
javascript minifier but that does also
some optimization so i was thinking just
to reuse this
this optimization passes to make my code
faster
but it turns out it wasn't such a great
idea
okay anyway and and at the end of course
this ast
goes through the generator and we get
a javascript code that is ready to be
to be run and played
okay there are two different types of
recompilation
there is static and dynamic
recompilation so the static
recompilation as the name implies
uses a static analysis so
basically it's done before the game
plays
before the game starts and on the other
hand we have a dynamic recompilation
so this uh type of recompilation
is actually working at runtime
when the game is playing it's
recompilating on the flight
okay now we're going to go on a
kind of case study i'm going to talk to
you about gs
js sms which is an emulator i build
using all these techniques
so first of all uh
when a um when the rom is is loaded into
the emulator
we start with a static recommendation so
what it does it's try to generate as
much code as possible
to um i mean to turn uh
most of the binary data into javascript
and so this is what's represented by
this
runtime on this on this graph but how
the problem we have is
recompilation as you can as you
know as you probably know induces
latency so it takes a while
to uh to generate javascript code from
uh from binary data
so that's why i in this example i
decided to
to generate code using static analysis
before the game starts because my my
guess was
it's better to have a player to
to wait uh before the game starts
because
uh so just to give you some figures
for recompilation uh of a
whole whole rom takes about
it depends on the rom but sometimes it's
around from let's say
300 milliseconds to two three seconds
so it's nothing but it's better to have
the player to wait before the game
starts because
if you can recompile as much javascript
as possible then we'll
make sure we'll have a game
veteran smooth smooth smoothly
okay so that's why there is a
everything starts with a static
recompilation
but we have an issue here is that static
analysis has limitations so
just using static analysis on the rom
file it's not
possible to compile entirely a rom file
into javascript
before because for on some cases
under some circumstances we can't know
uh just with static analysis what is
going to be
the next instruction to to execute
so that's why uh we can't do fully
uh statically
we can do full static recompilation
i mean at least on this particular video
console okay so then
we statically recompile the rom
and the game starts so when the game
starts
whenever we find a new instruction that
hasn't been generated
into javascript yet what we do is we
start
the dynamic compilation so everything
all the process start again so we have
the parser the analyzer optimizer and
generator
and then after the generator the
javascript code that we get
is appended to the pool of functions
that we already have from
the static uh recompilation
and that means that whenever the game is
played
when a function is played we can't
really know if it's
if it has been recompiled using the
static analysis or the dynamic
uh recompilation everything everything
belongs to the same uh pull off of
functions
okay and um
and also unlike
the static recompilation when you when
we do the
dynamic recompilation we only try to
compile
into javascript as few
code as possible we want to compile just
what's required
because this id is
because as i told you before when you do
recompilation uh when it takes
recompilation process takes some time so
that's why we want when the game is
playing
we want to have as few lags as possible
so that's why we just
we just recompile very few functions uh
when we do it at runtime
just before the benchmark i just wanted
to to add that
of course the more you play a game
the more likely you are
to the most likely
the more the more instructions are being
compiled into javascript
so the more you play a game the better
the faster and the smoother it gets
okay okay so now i guess it's benchmark
time so
how much faster is interpretation
as opposed to as compared to
recompilation
and this is what i get so this benchmark
was actually
made on uh i think i use my
gig's phone peak so
the figures from one from 0 to 40
is actually the fps so
the recompilation is actually
four to six times faster
than interpretation and also
this benchmark is done on on firefox
because i
targeted firefox right from the
beginning i
haven't really optimized my code for
chrome so that's why we
on chrome we don't get such a big
difference between both
types of emulation
and so why is
why do we have such a huge difference
between
both of the emulation but both of the
approaches for
emulation it's mainly because on
the case of a recompilation uh the
generated function can be easily
optimized
by the javascript vm
um so if you remember during the
interpret
interpreter the issue with an
interpreter is we
so we have a pointer so we increment the
pointer
read the value execute the
value of um sorry execute the
instruction associated
to the up code
and then start again increment the
counter and continue this way
so that's why it makes it extremely
difficult for uh vm to uh to optimize
such a code and that's why
compilation we get such a huge
difference
okay from the benchmark
i i did it runs
full speed on nexus 4 it runs off for
40 fps on on p on the peak
and around 30 fps on a
gig's phone kion so it's not that bad i
mean 38
fps it's a bit slow it's not normal
speed but
the game is still uh are still playable
so
it's quite good
um okay now i'm going to talk you about
alec so alec is a firefox
app so means you can install it on
firefox os
uh firefox for android and the firefold
desktop
so just as a side note alec is a
is i decided to call
this applica this web app alec because
uh alec is
you know remember the character alex
kidd yeah i think
you do and the
the japanese sometimes tend to uh to
shorten this name alex into alec so i
decided to use it
okay so so alec is an open source
uh firefox app that uses js sms
as the engine to run
to do emulation of sega master system
and
game gear is still under
development there are some things to do
like this some
on the recompiler some up codes are
missings
uh there's no sound the
control flow restrictoring can be
uh enhanced can be yeah can be better
and there are
ways of ways of optimization that can be
can be done
and also uh there's many things that we
that we can experiment well i have also
already experimental
experimented with different solutions to
make it fast
but there are still loads loads of
different things to do
so for example we could use webworker to
generate
a javascript function and in the
meantime
uh use fall back to the interpreter and
go back to the compiler when the
functions are ready to
to be executed uh
we could also use uh
generators to mimic the interrupts
and uh and use the web api user game
gamepad api wave has many many things to
do
and uh so everything everything is open
source so alec
and jssms the engine are open source so
uh pull requests are welcome so don't
hesitate to uh to contribute
uh okay that's about it so um
if you want to uh contact me the versus
my twitter account
there is also my github account and the
link if you want to
uh install i like on your on your
device thank you oh by the way
uh the slides were built using sam
which stands for simple adventure uh
game
adventure game maker something like this
it's basically so actually the slide
view view uh watch where a real
uh sega master system rom that i've
compiled specially for
for the occasion picture
and and and that's it so i just have a
few minutes left
so if you don't mind i'm going to show
you
how good i am at playing columns
up
there we go you
no no
normal i'm not taking any risks today
oh i have an issue i can't see all my
screen on my laptop anyway
oops
come on you can encourage me
yeah please
well this device i'm using is not very
fast so
um so i'm i'm not sure how much
uh how many fps i'm playing at
but as you can see it's still very
playable and very
still enjoyable so so that's it i'm
going to stop here
before i lose thank you
so uh so we have no time for question
but don't hesitate to
to grab me to grab me a bit shy but
i can i can be sociable if i want thank
you